[Music]
cool George Washington yeah this piece
is also called George Washington was a
douchebag in the limo are you ready to
invade the privacy of famous yeah I have
wooden teeth but I'm getting some
tonight at the club
alright well for example this is really
interesting to see well how it breaks
down Bernie Sanders we looked into it
Bernie Sanders 70% is campaign donations
10% of his money comes from u.s. Senator
salary 20% of his money comes from
heckling the Muppets from about Tommy
Lee Jones I was looking into this Tommy
Lee Jones 40% of his money comes from
film roles 30% of his money comes from
investments thirty percent comes from
loose change dug out of his crags yes
it's just financial information yeah no
reason to boo yeah we won't have that
yeah Oh Jay Simpson it's really
interesting 60% of his money comes from
sports memorabilia 40 percent comes from
murder no sports yeah
voices little monkey Sarah Palin we
looked into it Sarah Palin 30% comes
from getting it done for freedom and the
values 50% of her money comes from
talking about the lamestream media and
all that jazz 60 percent comes from
Maffin I was shocked to find this out
Axl Rose is back touring with Guns and
Roses there he is there he is Axl Rose
that's not a bundt cake bandana I'm told
Axl Rose thirty percent of his money
comes from touring 20% comes from
residuals fifty percent comes from
modeling for look like you're taking a
mean dump magazine surprisingly popular
magazine I did not know that was a
magazine Vin Diesel
this is shocking Vin Diesel 80% of his
money comes from movies ten percent
comes from endorsements 10% using head
to crack Biko's walnuts that's money
zeebee mouth just comes to your house if
you have walnuts he cracks yeah seize
them these damn crack see you later
you'll get my bill please damn he
doesn't talk like an articulate man
he's not the hole he's coming to your
house to crack nuts with his head
oh here we go
bish he would not go tees down only one
way to know for sure rats we've got to
get the money together to happen to it
let's go 5050 all right about 5050 you
will get Vin Diesel visas had to crack
some nuts come find out what he says
just beforehand all right guess what
we're pre-empting the Korea show this
Saturday 11:00 for that show man this is
complicated
hey check this out Jeb Bush let's see I
mean he makes his money Jeb Bush one
percent comes from speaking fees 99
percent comes from has rich parents Ted
Cruz Ted Cruz forty percent comes from
campaign donations 25% from appearance
fees 35 percent eating Billy Goats that
crosses bridge then stealing their
wallets even while running for president
he has time for under bridge role he's a
yeah he's a troll troll yeah how's it
class we'll check this out this one kind
of relates Billy Goats look at this
forty percent selling homemade cheese
thirty percent money found while eating
30 percent performing on pornographic
website for Saders now check this out
Andy seder Seder
make their money 60 percent comes from
circus freak shows 20 percent posing for
illustrated fantasy novels 20 percent
selling Ted Cruz fresh delicious
[Applause]
and finally Donald Trump okay 50 percent
comes from real estate 12 percent Trump
steaks eight percent Trump water 2
percent Trump dental floss 2 percent
Trump pony feed 1% Trump sugarless gum
1% Trump beach sandals 1% Trump tiny
eyeglass screwdrivers 1% trunk pinatas
1% Trump mufflers 1% Trump googly eyes
white % Trump lemons esters 1% Trump
medicated anti-inflammatory patches 1%
Trump cat toys 1% Trump parrot cages 1%
Trump 5 bean dip 1% Trump bookmarks 1%
Trump diet ginger ale 1% Trump calendars
wet percent Trump salad bar sneeze
guards went percent Trump frisbees 1%
Trump cocktail umbrellas 1% Trump's the
grout 1% Trump monorails
1% Trump ostrich saddles 1% 2% squeegees
weight percent truck hang glider's 1%
trunk lasers and 1% trump is an [ __ ]
bumper sticker
[Applause]
you
you